oder die stimme über die nächsten job ab
wieder freien modus relativ freien modus
so langsam versteht
jonas betrifft immer mehr in seinem
leben
klatschen wir aber für jonas das war es
für sie selber gut versteht zu spät auf
der bühne hält programm so fertig
montiert nicht wenigstens eine ahnung
was wir nicht das klatschen einer ja du
ja du bist aber nicht was wir machen
wollen und fahrräder klauen wollen wir
haben wir uns brutto holen frieda
paragliding flugzeuge die welt in gta 5
ist unglaublich groß kann man eine couch
apple ihn fliegen ja kann man euch auch
das wäre geil wo kann man sich den
zeppelin können also war es denn oder
braucht man dafür die lcd und das frage
ich mich dort auch ich habe ein video
gesehen mich beim vorbestellen zu einem
code bekommen ich hatte noch nie
eingelöst ich habe keinen code und ich
hab das nicht vorgestellt ich war nur im
laden und habe da ja ich will meine
karre sogar ein bisschen bei mir drin
komm zu mir
ja ich bin gar nicht so weit weg sogar
abgeschleppt weil der typ da wird
abgeschleppt und die haben einfach unser
und dann sagt er fragte mich wo man
jetzt kratzer herkommen vorher irgendwo
hinfahren wo sie bei mir eine karre ist
auch ganz schön ganz schön ich ja schon
die schwarze farbe freigeschaltet du
bist so witzig jonas wie kann man so
witzig sein wie du ich hab noch bei
einem spiel in dem wir fahren jetzt
einfach mal auf dem berg da oben drauf
geht das jetzt unser ziel eine bergen
liegt in die berg ob das alles klappt
weil ich glaube dass ich dachte ich
sterbe bringst du uns dann alle um
nein ich schaffe das jetzt in einem
macht man ihm seine indiana jones musik
mache ja so eine vermutlich mache jetzt
ich mache jetzt mach ich jetzt mit der
einmal musik wo ich so richtig richtig
motivation kriegt jetzt rot losgefahren
ich komme mir aus ich habe diese
offenbar steine auf die steine die
können darauf was ich für das anliegen
boots coots ich hoffe wir sind den
heftigsten die schießen auf uns weil du
hast auf die geschossen
lasst euch dass eine beschneidung von
denen für jonas ist da schon auf der
minimap fahren ganz wie die aktie jetzt
längst ja du willst so hätten ich will
auf den anderen berg auf denen da oben
kann man ja man kann überall hin meinten
die entwickler dann werden wir morgen
nein der bluttat waren für mich du bist
kacke wer ist einfach ohne t shirt
wir haben stern ich dachte ich wurde
weil er als würde ich schwöre dir das
ist der richtige weg
wir können auch offroad fahren vor jetzt
machten ja ich kann nicht fahren
er ist wie seine frau meinte wendt
forderte jetzt einfach kaputt angemessen
zu deiner autofarbe ich finde das ist
richtig schwer zu fallen wenn ein reifen
kaputt ist diese massen auch die reifen
kann man schießt ja noch nicht auf meine
reifen geschossen nachtquartier keinen
fall ich glaube erst gar nicht kaputt
ist doch wirklich nicht gefahren ich
sehe nicht nennen ich hasse solche
strauß der war nicht da immer nicht
richtig gut ich gerade beim skaten
so wie jetzt schon oben bitte das
gericht seine jungs gehören here oder
alltagsleben und bis nach den falschen
weg gefragt weil ich war dort ist die
straße ich brauche deine musik da bin
ich ja auch noch die strafe bekommen
ich habe aber ein bisschen angst ehrlich
gesagt mache musik machst du musst da wo
ich dachte jetzt ist es wäre ein
richtiger ab haben da unten alte okay
geht noch war die landhof überrannt wird
habe lieber kinzler nochmal gleich
moment rosenberg und die haben einfach
das geld zum fall dass wir haben nicht
mal angeschossen als auch nicht einfach
respekt vor der karl wir haben sterben
ja weil du einfach zu 50 fährst du hast
nicht am schießen
ich glaube das ist ganz auf mich ich
habe möge paar angefasst ok aus dem auto
gummi frau hier wird ja mit der typisch
von tiefster ist oder
einfach mit nürnberg schießt ihr hier
jetzt hab ich nichts ich zeige dir nun
mit dem körper stelle von schießler den
mittelfinger gezeigt ich kann nicht mehr
ich dir irgendwie die facebook
eingestellt
die polizei ist ja einfach auf einmal
hier sind jetzt ich habe auch eins
bekommen ok dann müssen dann wissen wir
schon auf jeden fall aber ich habe nur
ausdauer wieder und ich ganz so nicht
mehr laufen aus dem wesen fit ist
wir beide es kann ein wettrennen
zwischen zwei eheleuten langsam eine
spezielle kurse sind fettes fährt was
rennen will ich glaube dass einfach die
leutenberger bolt jetzt natürlich
windschatten ausnutzen
er wollte hier schon runter springt
einfach auf der plattform oben ich weiß
nicht warum das ist so ein stück
wir gehen einfach auf die auf diesen es
ist einfach kann sich die versicherung
rufen und die bringen dir dein auto oder
muss das irgendwo abholen
ich weiß nicht vielleicht dein auto ist
schrott die kontakte
heute hören sein taxi taxi anruf beruf
zu taxieren ich rufe versicherung juso
in den charts was meinen die den mars
mission in cheryls wert gewählt ich
glaub ich hab keine verbindung alle
mitarbeiter von nietzsche sind derzeit
im gespräch sind versuchen sie es später
wieder
[Musik]
sie hat mir gesagt ja mal anpacken was
ich noch nie bergfeld junge menschen
kämpfen kugeln die an muss ich
motivierende die luft schießen ja nein
[Gelächter]
das einfach auto ehemann
ich wollte nein das war gar nicht
gewollt nee ich wollte die motiviert in
die wirkweise an dieses über ich bin
irgendwo wo bist du mann rückte die
aufnahme ja ich würde aus einem anderen
werk ausgebaut werden
ich glaub ich bin sogar vor dir da ich
eine abkürzung jetzt guckt wo ich mit
auf der karte aber ich kannte diese
stein war nur wie so ein steinbock alter
mann hat jetzt tritt als landwirt
schwarzen koffer kopfhörern gesehen
fallen da sind nicht mal koffer lassen
lärmschutz träger allgemeine läuft alter
dass wir irgendwo runterspringen camp
rock bis jetzt noch nie so lachen noch
eins braucht hier ist noch nicht die
folge neuer geh da habe ich auch noch
jonas beckmann bitte ganz kurz stehen
einmal ich muss sagen das testen mich
überholen will sie das ist ein
aerodynamik
meine tollen lackschuhe auf jeden fall
ist so ein arsch in der hose
mein tipp stirbt bald hat er stirbt
gleich
ja ja ja das nein der wahlrat fast am
verrecken
ich würde da oben ist sie aber schon wir
sind da wurde er immer war das gibt es
noch verlangen hey lass mal jetzt schon
runter springen ja ja ich weiß wir
wieder schaffen
sie war um nachher fallen wegen gegen
seinen freund und mein gott schuf
youtube adrenalin kick
achtung da sind wollen wir da warte ich
auf die da oben das kann noch ganz
diplomatisch um bestände jetzt baut
darum bestimmt gleich wieder polizei
ja weil wir nicht früher wanderer
getroffen nun gut kombiniert werden da
liegt dann statt wenn der bus um einen
schwarzen wo sind die böden alter wollen
sich einfach vor uns gespannt sind da
rufen schon gleich gut aber auch der
videoweb kommen auf der mini werden die
sind einfach da kommt ja gleich runter
gefahren ja in 54 32
aber die sehen uns gerade gar nicht also
ich würde nicht um die kurve laufen ich
sehe ich hab dann siehst du den abstieg
so
das können wir die letzten erfolge box
bin ich nicht lieber zu fuß
ich fühle mich da ein gesicherter
rausgehen nur bloß das nicht um einen
gott jonas du bist gar nicht ernsthaft
den berg runter gerüchte nicht ganz aber
ein bisschen weh heute aber das auto
klettern dabei ist das auto auch wieder
die bullen hier sind überall wohlmann
du musst sie im bus verstecken du bist
jetzt unten verberge alter aber müssen
die bullen hier töten verstecke ich nie
verstecken ist das schon ein helikopter
das einfach bringt groß wie mache ich
auch aber ich brauche ich nein ich weiß
nein nein das kann ich einfach rein
ja ich habe die falsche geöffnet war ich
bin der bub richtig geil dies mich
fliegen ja ich sehe ich das regenbogen
ich fliege jetzt sich die
hochspannungsleitung bisschen energie
mitnehmen
ja ich stärke immer müssen es war schön
ich hasse das heißt was sind die ersten
linien oder macht das automatisch auf
start des laufs i lon ich mach's das
schön einfach mal so zugegriffen
ich habe die polizei übrigens abgehängt
ich fliege wieder zurück zum berg könnte
ja ich auch du dich sterben
komm mach doch wie macht er das ist ja
toll jetzt wo ich muss gegen die nach
unten sonst ich habe keinen zweiten fall
schimmel so ich liebe es nach unten
ich werde es ein bisschen mehr luft ich
hoffe da kommt vielleicht zu mir ja ich
bin
hast du ein jetpack vielleicht deswegen
ich wollte einfach gewartet
ich bin und was ich jetzt gleich ich
frage ja wie ich hier oben vom berg
irgendwann mal so das schaffe so
abzuspringen dass wir dieses kribbeln
cup springen kann es ja auch viereck ja
aber dann springe ich einfach so machen
coole wolle
ach ich bin auch ich lerne jetzt auf dem
dach alter wo mein gott wie geil das ist
wie james bond gerade ich fühle mich so
geil ich guck mir dann wollen wir ja
jetzt erst einmal weihnachtsbaum kaufen
[Musik]
das ist so deprimierend weil ich diesen
kompletten berg hochgefahren
beziehungsweise gelaufen sind
dies ist meine schüsse kommen die
irgendwie oben an
er gibt es nicht auch keine konnte baten
ja ich glaube das war doch der sinn
dieser platz direkt daneben
ich bin erlebe ich dass ich top nicht
wie komme ich denn jetzt hier runter
oder zu sterben wie komme ich zu dir ist
zu folgen und die sonne geht dann
schaffe ich das
wo mein gott ich bin ich habe ein
bisserl leben
wenn ich irgendwo unter falle bin ich
nahezu tot okay gut
wo gehe ich